>> Well, let's take a look. Your intuition
may be telling you that the second rule, which
is more specific, should be faster because well, it's
more precise, but actually the opposite is true. The
first rule tells us that whenever we encounter an
h1 tag, we should set the font size to
16 pixels. Pretty simple. The second rule is trickier.
First, it says that we should match any paragraph
tag, like the one we have here. But then, once we find
the paragraph tag, we should walk up the DOM tree and only
apply this rule if there's a div element as its parent. As
a result, this more specific tag actually requires more work from the browser.
>> Hm, oh wow, so the more specific rule is more
expensive because it has to traverse more nodes in the DOM tree.
>> That's right. Exactly. That said, before you go all crazy and rewrite all
of your rules, measure first. Chances are
selector matching is not your performance model link.
>> So, I shouldn't worry about it?
>> Well, I didn't say that. Measure first, optimize second.
And speaking of measure, let's take a look at dev tools.